My name's Molly Mackinlay, I'm from Belleview Washington and I'm a senior here
at Stanford. And I first got into computer science when I was doing a first
robotics program at my high school. I didn't take any coding classes until I
got to Sanford and I took CS106A, my freshman year, fall quarter. And I loved
it, but before that I thought I was interested in math, science, maybe
engineering. And so I took an engineering course in the summer at Cornell
University, trying to figure out if that's something I was interested in. And
there I got to tour their HCI lab, which is Human Computer Interaction, and
that studies how people interact with technology. And I was really interested
in how to design technology for people. And make it something that was going to
be both effective and really useful for them and that's what really got me
excited about exploring CS. Because computer science is all about designing and
solving problems that are going to be useful for the people that are using
these programs. And so from there I took a lot of really amazing CS classes
here. And from there I was sold. And I took the rest of the CS classes and had
a really great time with it.